28 million pounds we've donated to
kovacs
i therefore wish to correct the
suggestion from the
european council president that the uk
has blocked
vaccine exports let me be clear we have
not
blocked the export of a single covid19
vaccine
or vaccine components this pandemic has
put us all on the same side in the
battle for global health
we oppose vaccine nationalism in all its
forms
i trust that all sides of the house will
join me in rejecting
this suggestion and calling on all our
partners to work together to tackle this
pandemic mr speaker this morning i had
meetings with ministerial colleagues and
others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings
later today let's go to daisy cooper
daisy thank you mr speaker
the government is throwing a staggering
37 billion
at a test and trace system that we know
has made barely any difference
but yet it says that it cannot afford to
give more than a pitiful 1
pay rise to nhs workers the prime
minister has said that he owes his
life to them he stood on the steps of
number 10
and applauded them so will the prime
minister
do more than pay lip service and pay
them the wage
that they deserve prime minister
mr speaker she is indeed right that we
owe a huge amount to
our nurses and incalculable debt and
that's why i'm proud that we've
delivered a 12.8 percent increase in the
starting salary
of nurses and they're asking the public
say block paper review body
to look at increasing their pay
exceptionally of all
uh the professions in the public section
as for test and trace
mr speaker it is thanks to nhs test and
trace
that we're able to send kids back to
school and begin
cautiously and irreversibly to reopen
our economy and restart
our lives let's go to geiger mahindra
gotham thank you mr speaker i
recently visited long marston bovington
rickmansworth and birkenstead to see the
damage the flooding
caused to our communities first hand can
the prime minister assure this house
that as the weather gets better we do
not lose the momentum of finding
long-term sustainable solutions to
prevent flooding
in the future and to give residents the
security they deserve
all year round irrespective of the
weather outside
hi minister i thank my honourable friend
for what he's doing to campaign for his
uh local area for flood defenses i want
to thank the environment agency for
their
tireless and imaginative and creative
work that they do to find solutions and
uh we're investing 5.2 billion pounds to
build 2 000 new flood
defenses over the next six years we now
come to the leader of the opposition
kirsten
[Music]
who does the prime minister think
deserves a pay rise more
an nhs nurse or dominant cummings
mr speaker i as as i told the
honourable lady for the liberal
democrats uh earlier on
uh we owe a massive debt as a society
and uh i personally uh to the nurses of
our nhs and that's why we've asked the
public sector pay review body
exceptionally to look at uh their pay i
want to stress
however as the house knows that uh
starting salaries for nurses have gone
up
uh by 12.8 percent over the last three
years
and it is thanks to the package that
this government has put in place
uh that we now have ten thousand six
hundred
more nurses in our nhs mr speaker than
there were
one year ago and sixty thousand more in
training
mr speaker he says nurse's pay has gone
up i know he's desperate to distance
himself from the conservatives record
over the last decade as he well knows
since 2010
nurses pay his fallen in real terms by
more than 800 pounds
and he didn't answer my question it was
a very simple question
he's been talking about affordability he
could
he could afford to give dominic cummings
a 40
pay rise he could afford that now he's
asking nhs nurses to take a real term
pay cut
how on earth does he justify that
mr speaker as i i repeat the point that
i
have made i i believe that we all owe a
massive
uh debt to our nurses indeed all our uh
health care workers and our social care
workers and uh one of the things that uh
they tell me when i go
uh to hospitals mr speakers i know the
right audience gentleman does is that in
addition to
to pay one of their chop their top
concerns is to have
more colleagues on the wards to help
them with the undoubted stress
and strains of the pandemic and that's
why we provided another 5 000 pounds in
bursaries
for nurses another 3 000 to help them
with the particular costs
of training and with childcare mr
speaker and it's because of that package
that this year
i believe we're seeing another 34
increase in applications
for nurses and we are on target this
government
this government of this party of the nhs
is on target
to deliver 50 000 more nurses
in our nhs mr speaker
mr speaker he talks about recruitment
there are currently
40 000 nursing vacancies 40 000 and 7
000 doctor's vacancies
how on earth does he think a pay cut is
going to help solve that
and frankly i'd take the prime minister
a bit more seriously
if he hadn't spent 2.6 million pounds of
taxpayers money
on a downing street tv studio or two
hundred thousand pounds or new wallpaper
for his flat
mr speaker they say charity starts at
home but i think prime minister's
taking a bit too literally let me try
something very simple
does the prime minister accept does the
prime minister accept
that nhs staff will be hundreds of
pounds
worse off a year because of last
week's budget no i know mr speaker
because
uh and of course we will look at what
the independent pay review body has to
say
uh exceptionally about the the nursing
profession whom we particularly
uh particularly value but what he should
also know uh
which he uh should reflect to the house
is that under this government uh we not
only began by a record increase
uh in nhs funding over i think 33.9
billion pounds but
because of the pandemic we put another
63 billion pounds
into supporting our nhs specific on top
of the 140 billion pounds
of india spending and it's because of
this government that in one year
alone mr speaker there are another 49
000 people working in our nhs and that i
think
is something that is of massive benefit
not just to patients
but to hard-pressed nurses as well
[Music]
mr speaker my mum was a nurse
my sister was a nurse my wife works in
the nhs i know what it means to work for
the nhs
when i clap for carers i meant it he
clapped for carers then he shut the door
in their face at the first opportunity
and the more you look at the prime
minister decision
the worse it gets because it's not just
a
pay cut it's a broken promise to
time and time again he said that the nhs
wouldn't pay the price for this pandemic
two years ago
he made a promise to the nhs here in
black and white
his document it commits to a minimum pay
rise of 2.1
it's been budgeted for and now it's
being taken away
he shakes his head his mp's voted for it
so why
after everything the nhs has done for us
is he now breaking promise
after promise prime minister uh mr
speaker he he voted against the document
in
uh in question and she's going to crown
the absurdity of it
uh at his point uh this under this under
this government
we have massively increased funding uh
for our
amazing nhs with the result as i say
there are six thousand
five hundred more doctors uh this year
than there were
last year uh 18 000 more health care uh
workers
and 10 600 more nurses and we're going
to go on mr speaker and we are going to
deliver our promises i can tell the
right honourable general we are going to
go on and we're going to build
uh 40 more hospitals and we're going to
recruit 50
000 more nurses and we're going to get
on and deliver on our pledges to the
british people and we're going to do
that
because of our sound management of the
economy
and the fastest vaccine rollout program
of any comparable country
which frankly uh if we'd followed uh his
precepts and his ideas
uh we would certainly not have been able
to achieve
[Music]
he says he voted for it he did and now
he's ripped it up
2.1 ripped up
and if the prime minister won't listen
to me he should listen to what his own
conservative mps are saying about this
his own side this is what they say
behind you prime minister
it's inept it's unacceptable
it's pathetic these are conservative mps
about the prime minister's pay cut for
nurses and that's before his answers
today
another evp said this mr speaker and
this is perhaps the most telling of all
the comments
this mp said sitting behind him the
public just hear one percent
and they think how mean we are
mr speaker even his own mps know he's
got this wrong
why is he going ahead with it uh mr
speaker what the public know
is that we're increasing uh pay for
starting pay for nurses by 12.8
over the last three years uh they know
that this government
uh in the last year has put another 5
000 pound bursary into the pockets
of nurses because we support them and as
well as the 3 000 extra
for training and of course it's very
very important that the public sector
pay review body
uh should come back uh with its
proposals and we will of course
study them but as i say it is thanks to
the investment made by this government
that there are 49
000 more people in the nhs this year
than last year
10 600 more nurses helping
to relieve the burden on our
hard-pressed nurses that is what this
government is investing in
kirsten speaker he says we support them
we'll reward them
he's cutting their pay mr speaker
not true he says not true
prime minister a 1 rise versus 1.7
inflation rise that is a real terms
cut and if the prime minister doesn't
understand that we really are in trouble
mr speaker they promised honesty
but the truth is they can afford to give
dominic cummings a 40
tax right pay rise and they can't afford
to reward the nhs properly
the mask really is slipping and we can
see what the conservative party now
stands for
cutting pay for nurses putting taxes up
on families
he's had the opportunity to change
course
but he's refused so if he's so
determined to cut nhs pay
we at least show some courage and put it
to a vote in this parliament
mr speaker the last time we've had put
in a vote he voted against it
as i as i said before we're increasing
uh pay for
nurses uh we're massively increasing our
investment uh in the nhs
we're we are steering a steady course
whereas he weaves and and wobbles
from one week to the next mr speaker one
one week he's
he's attacking us uh saying we should be
doing more testing the next week
he's denouncing us for uh for doing it
for spending money on on testing one
week he calls not so fast to roll out of
pp the next week he's saying we spent
too
too much mr speaker uh he's got it he's
got he's got to make his he got his make
his mind one thing he calls her a faster
vaccination rollout when he actually
voted and then he
claims to have forgotten it uh to stay
in the european medicines age perhaps
he'd like to
perhaps he'd like to confirm that he
voted to stay in the european medicines
agency
mr speaker we should have made that
vaccine roll out impossible
we vaccinate we get on with delivering
for the people of this country
we vaccinate he vaccinates mr speaker
and that's the difference
thank you mr speaker the incredible
success
of our vaccination programme for which
the prime minister
and this government deserve immense
credit
now means that tourism businesses in
blackpool
can look forward to a successful summer
season when the economy
reopens when the time is right will the
prime minister
support the campaign encouraging people
to holiday
here in the uk this summer and will he
join me in blackpool to launch that
campaign
and to showcase everything we have to
offer yeah
well mr speaker i will look very
carefully at my diary to see whether i
can actually get up to black people i
have many happy memories of joyful
evenings uh spectating at the
illuminations of
blackpool and i know that blackpool will
play uh an important part in the
uh than the tourism recovery that we
hope to see this summer if we continue
on our roadmap we have technical issues
with the leader of the smp so i'm going
to ask kirsten oswalt
as the deputy leader to stand in
christian oswald mr speaker
yesterday the prime minister published
his plans for an erasmus replacement
without any consultation or discussion
with devolved governments
the replacement scheme offers lower
living support
no travel support no tuition fee support
why is this tory government taking
opportunities away from our young people
well mrs because she is a
delightfully concise question i may say
uh but uh
she is wrong about the difference in the
erasmus and the turing
uh project because the the turing scheme
uh unlike the erasmus scheme which
overwhelmingly
uh went to kids from better off homes
the turing project is designed
to help kids across the country of all
income groups get to fantastic
universities around the world
christine mr speaker that's just not the
case we know we can't
trust a word the prime minister says on
this he he told us
there's no threat to the erasmus scheme
but he clearly won't match eu levels of
support
and it's not just us saying it his own
scottish colleague told the bbc last
week
young people won't benefit from brexit
he's they've saddled our generation with
tuition feed out now they're closing the
door with erasmus it's no wonder
that students are choosing snp and
independence
for a prosperous future so prime
minister will you think again will you
do the right thing
engage with our eu friends and rejoin
erasmus
can i just remind members not to use you
prime minister
uh thank you mr speaker no i think uh
students should choose
the turing project because it's
fantastic and it uh reaches out across
the whole
uh the whole country and i believe by
the way mr speaker they should reject uh
the smp because it's totally
uh a a scottish a scottish nationalist
party mr speaker
because it is uh because it is failing
it is failing the people of
uh failing the people of scotland
failing to deliver on
on education uh failing on crime and
failing
on the economy and i i think that the i
hope very much that the people of
scotland will go for common sense and
instead of
endlessly going on about constitutional
issues instead of instead of endlessly
campaigning for a referendum which i
think the lot is the last thing the
people of this country need
right now i think people want a
government that focuses
on the issues that matter to them
including
a fantastic uh international education
scheme
like turin right let's go to jeremy
right
jeremy thank you very much mr speaker my
right honourable friend will recognize
that while covered restrictions have
been in place
children have not only had to learn
online rather than in the classroom but
have also missed out on cultural
artistic and sporting activities with
their peers
at the same time cultural artistic and
sporting organizations
have remained restricted in what they
can do and despite the considerable help
offered to them are still in need of
government support so can i ask him to
consider
how we might put those two things
together and provide for enrichment
activities available to all young people
over the coming months funded by
government and provided not by
hard-pressed teachers
but by our outstanding culture and
sports sectors
while they're unable to reopen to the
wider public
my right honourable friend has been a
great champion of the arts and culture
sectors and he's
he's completely right about the role
that they can play uh for young people
in the recovery and that's why
the massive two billion pound recovery
fund that uh
we've uh we've we've given uh to
thousands of theaters and
orchestras choirs and music venues and
others uh we hope will be used uh for
the benefit
and the uh the cultural enrichment of
young people up and down the country
call of duty thank you mr speaker the
prime minister's fantasy
bridge to northern ireland could cost 33
billion
pounds this while our road and real
networks have been absolutely decimated
from decades of under investment the
conservative party got a grand total
of 2 300 2399 votes
at the last assembly election what
mandate does he think he has
to override the democratically elected
people
of northern ireland to impose a bridge
that goes through
miles of unexploded munitions and
radioactive waste
mr speaker actually if you read the the
article i wrote this morning in the
daily telegraph uh he would have seen
that
uh the the things that uh we've set out
in the handy
review i think would be a massive
benefit to northern ireland uh
including upgrading uh the a75 which is
the single biggest thing that people in
uh northern ireland wanted by the way
which the scottish nationalists have
totally
national party have totally failed uh to
do as well as better connections
uh east west within uh northern ireland
which we should be doing
as well as where the better connections
north south within the island
of ireland it's a fantastic union
connectivity
review uh he should appreciate it it's
the way forward and i'm
amazed frankly at his negativity
paul holmes thank you mr speaker
despite the claims of easily liberal
democrats my constituents will be
delighted to know that the concrete
section of the m27
will start to be resurfaced this summer
does the prime minister agree that this
shows that it is conservative
governments that invest in
infrastructure
and that if elected in may conservative
candidates like jerry hall
will deliver deliver for the people of
eastleigh hedge end and west end
it's absolutely true mr speaker it is
conservative governments who
uh who invest in if this conservative
government is putting 640 billion pounds
into an infrastructure revolution and i
congratulate jerry hall
on what is uh what he's doing uh to to
resurface the
road and to make it uh quieter and i and
i hope that he will be
duly elected in may
[Applause]
david london thank you very much mr
speaker
in extending the 20 pounds uplift
universal credit which we welcome at the
beginning the pandemic the prime
minister was clearly conceding
that social security support in the uk
is inadequate so while welcome the fact
has been extended for six months i'd
like to see it being made permanent but
can you tell the house why
if it was so inadequate why it wasn't
extended to those on legacy benefits
such as disabled people
mr speaker throughout the pandemic we've
done whatever we can to
look after uh people throughout the
country
they're on uh benefits or those who have
lost their jobs sadly because of the
of the pandemic and uh and i'm very
proud of what universal credit has been
able
uh to achieve and i think that he should
perhaps take it up with
uh his friends in the labour party you
actually want to abolish universal
credit
with no goal to leonichi leah
mr speaker last week grimsby celebrated
the
chancellor's announcements of the towns
fund and the humber freeport
and it's clear to the people of brimsby
that it's this government
that is determined not to neglect the
town like labour predecessors
our next challenge is to raise skills
and education as
achievement in the town and would the
prime minister outline
how people can take advantage of the new
lifetime skills guarantee
that he's launching next month thank you
well mr speaker the fantastic thing
about the lifetime skills guarantee
is that in very very tough circumstances
with many people uh having
i'm afraid inevitably to uh to seek new
jobs to find ways of
of retraining as will happen in a
changing
economy it offers everybody uh adults
uh over 23 the opportunity uh 3 000
pounds
on an a-level equivalent uh
qualification i think will be
absolutely instrumental in helping uh in
helping
young people out beyond school age
to retrain and get the jobs they need
the lifetime skills guarantees the first
time it's been done mr speaker
right let's go to claire hammer
thank you very much mr speaker it takes
some 16
000 dedicated nurses to staff northern
ireland's health service costing
around 380 million pounds per year
that's less than two percent of uk sales
for just one internet giant
amazon whose revenues doubled during
lockdown
what possible reason can the prime
minister on his chancellor who both
talked about the need to pay for this
pandemic have
to not apply a modest windfall tax on
those businesses who have benefited
so much from the pandemic in order to
properly pay
those staff who have worked so hard to
bring us through the pandemic
actually i think that she's making an
important point about the discrepancy in
the tax paid
uh by some uh online businesses and
and some concrete businesses and that's
a an issue which the
the chancellor is trying to address in
an equitable way uh working
uh with colleagues in the g7 and around
the world
let's go to cheryl murray cheryl
thank you mr speaker mr speaker we've
seen the disgraceful way the eu have
responded
to uk fish exports part of the answer is
for uk consumers to buy british fish
as chairman of the appg for fisheries
could i invite the prime minister to
join a fantastic british chef
to show how easy it is to prepare and
cook a dish using british caught fish
well i'm very happy to to take up my
honourable friend's suggestion i'm not
the greatest chef myself
uh but i will i have i have made and can
make
uh from memory uh a fish pie with
haddock and prawns which i
undertake to do mr speaker british adult
thank you mr speaker prime minister
people like my constituent tessa stevens
have had to keep their salons shut
despite shrinking government support
unchanged overheads and decreased
profits i am
urgently seeking the prime minister's
support to protect the immediate and
long-term recovery of beauty businesses
and the jobs it supports
will the prime minister explain why his
government refuses to listen to the
beauty industry
who are calling for v80 to be
temporarily reduced to five percent
for hair and beauty businesses similar
to what has happened to other sectors
like hospitality tourism and culture
businesses
she's absolutely right in what she says
about the importance of uh
beauty uh businesses they do an amazing
job
and uh we want them to bounce back very
strongly uh from the pandemic and i want
high street beauty salons to be opening
up in the
in the in the way that they were in the
in the past rather than uh
people going around uh giving services
at uh
cutting hair at home i think it's very
important we revive uh high street sales
and that's why
uh we are continuing uh with the
cautious but irreversible
uh road map out of this which i think
will enable
a a full recovery for the entire sector
but in the meantime as
she knows the chancellor's extended
furlough and all the other provisions
that are necessary thank you mr speaker
can i warmly welcome
the union connectivity review that's
been announced this morning it's
brilliant news
to connect the whole of the uk but in
west dorset mr speaker we have
single track railway lines we have a
three hourly
rail frequency yet we have the highest
level of roadside pollution anywhere in
the uk
will my right honourable friends kindly
support a leveling up rail proposal that
will not only look to support west
dorset
but also some of the most deprived areas
in the southwest
my honourable friend knows where of he
he speaks he's probably one of the
greatest experts on uh
railways in this in this house and uh
we're certainly determined to
uh follow his lead and to upgrade
services in the
in the west country and endorse it uh he
knows what's happening at
dawlish and elsewhere and uh we've uh
network rail has identified uh proposals
including
uh approval of the uh performance of the
west of england line which is currently
uh being assessed but he's he's knocking
at an open door mr speaker
right let's go to dan carvin damn
thank you mr speaker back in 2012
commissioning for alcohol and drug
addiction treatment was taken out of the
nhs
and handed to local authorities and
those services
are now overwhelmed after a decade of
cuts and fragmentation
and last year the uk recorded the
highest number
of alcohol specific deaths since records
began
addiction is an illness that can be
treated
so will the prime minister urgently
investigate
the rise in debts and bring addiction
treatment back into the nhs within
mental health services
and give it the funding it requires
prime minister
he's entirely right mr speaker to draw
attention to
the importance of addiction treatment
and uh its relationship to mental health
and
that's why the government is investing
record sums uh in
um in mental health uh 13.3 billion
pounds
mr speaker and of course treatment for
alcoholism
is part of that let's go to the o'clock
theo
thank you mr speaker i've seen
first-hand visiting
both distant george's and county
hospitals in stafford
the great work that is being done to
support people
including veterans with their mental
health but does my right honorable
friend
agree with me that sadly the covert 19
pandemic is likely
to have had a negative impact on
people's mental health
and will he commit to working with me
and the stafford mental health network
to improve and increase the mental
health provision in stafford
yes mr speaker i i i was certainly very
happy to
uh discuss that uh with my honourable
friend or make sure that she gets access
to
uh the the uh the relevant ministerial
uh authority but
what we're doing in addition to the 13.3
uh billion that uh i spoke of
we've been supporting mental health
charities throughout the uh
pandemic and particularly focusing on
the mental health needs
of children and young people which is
why i appointed dr alex george
to be our youth mental health ambassador
mr speaker
this government is failing young people
before the pandemic apprenticeship
starts we're down by 28
for under 19 year olds 330 million pound
unspent levy back to the treasury
falling short by 81
in creating the promised hundred
thousand new apprenticeships
this month i will be holding my fifth
apprenticeships and jobs fair
in bristol south will he join me in
urging all young people
to support that fair in bristol south
but will he apologize to them for
failing them so far
exactly uh mr speaker i think jobs fairs
are an important thing and i know that
colleagues across the house
uh do them but i also think that the
government can be proud of the record
that we
we've had in getting record numbers of
young people uh into
employment we're now faced with a very
severe problem caused by
the pandemic and that's why we're
addressing it not just with the lifetime
skills guarantee that i
mentioned earlier on but also with the
kickstart funds
the restart funds uh two billion pounds
going into kickstart
alone to help young people into the jobs
that they need
tell me more thank you mr speaker after
putting in a fantastic bid southport
last week got a 37.5 million pounds
towns deal this will be transformational
and represents
the leveling up agenda of the prime
minister and this conservative
government
when his diary allows will he come to
southport to see these projects as they
unfold
and the impact they'll have on the lives
of my constituents
yes indeed mr speaker i'm told that the
uh that the boulevard of light on lord
street rivals the schwarzenegger
uh itself and i will certainly keep my
honourable friends invitation in mind
thank you mr speaker in this house we
all know the importance of those people
who've looked after our vulnerable loved
ones over the past year when we have
been unable to do so
so will the prime minister explain to me
why in this country
we have 375 000 care workers
on a zero hours contract
mr speaker i'm proud of what the
government has done to increase the
wages of
care workers across the country with the
biggest with record increases in the
in the living wage and uh this country
is unlike most other countries in
uh in the world in the speed with which
we've vaccinated care home
uh workers mr speaker and uh their
elderly charges
james grundy james thank you mr speaker
first of all may i thank the prime
minister for his commitment to
leveling up the north the benefits of
which we are already beginning to see
with a 15 million pound allocation from
the government's transforming cities
fund
enabling the plans to reopen golden
station in my constituency of lead to
progress
would the prime minister not only
welcome this progress but also back my
campaign to reopen kenyan junction
railway station
which will help unlock the potential of
lee provided by constituents
with a vital rail connection between
liverpool and manchester
and ensure lee is no longer one of the
largest towns in the uk
without a railway station prime minister
mr speaker i'm very happy to support my
honourable friends uh
initiative and i i i understand that
uh the goldman which he which he
represents uh was the site of the
world's very first railway
junction mr speaker let's go to ellin
smith allen smith
thank you mr speaker anthony jones a
ferociously bright student at sterling
university
was looking to do a masters in amsterdam
pre-brexit the course fees were 2
168 pounds post brexit the fees are 14
600 pounds the turing scheme won't touch
the sides of what's necessary
would the prime minister like to
apologize to anthony and countless
hundreds of thousands of students like
him for limiting their life horizons
against their will
mr speaker because i think that the
turing scheme is is fairer
and it's something that will enable
students on lower incomes to have access
to courses at a great courses around the
world and i believe it's a highly
uh beneficial reform uh to the way we do
that it's a truly global
and it's uh in its ambitions thank you
mr speaker a new station at mia
and investing in longton station and
also restoring
the stoked elite line will my right
honourable friends the prime minister
agree with me
that investment from this government has
the potential to reverse the beaching
cuts restore our local railways and
stoke on trent
and cement our position as one of the
best places connected in the whole uk
yeah yes i thank my honourable friend i
know he supported the bid for the
reinstatement of the stoke to leak line
uh it's currently being assessed by the
department uh for transport as one of
the beaching
reversals which are so popular around
the country and so right
and he can expect an outcome in the
summer mr speaker
let's go to dan jarvista
if the prime minister is serious about
leveling up the country
does he honestly think that favoring the
chancellor's richmond sheer constituency
over barnsley for financial support is
the best way to do it
mr speaker we've uh we are devoted
uh to leveling up across the entire
country and
uh that goes for that goes for barnsley
as well as everywhere else
let's go to chris grelling chris mr
speaker thank you
i know the prime minister shares my
commitment to conservation around the
world
and i'm sure in particular he agrees we
have got to reverse the tide of
deforestation
will he ask ministers in detroit to look
seriously at my proposals for a kite
mark scheme
for food products in the uk so consumers
can see
clearly whether or not the products they
buy come from sustainable sources
or whether they're coming from producers
who are doing further damage to our
environment
prime minister very happy to look at my
right honourable friends a very
interesting suggestion for a
for a kite mark scheme but in the
meantime this government is leading the
world
uh in tackling deforestation with a
three billion pound
uh investment uh being led across
whitehall